Everyone experiences stress from time to time, but how do you know when your stress has become too much? Is it when you stop sleeping properly, when your weekends are spent recovering from the week that's gone before, or when you're still functioning but everything feels harder than it should be? And perhaps one of the most important questions is how much of the pressure you're actually carrying belongs to you. Today, I want to help you work out where your stress is coming from, what you can change, and when you might want to start taking that more seriously. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a clinical psychologist, and this is psychology actually. Before we get started, if you are watching or listening to this,
每个人都会时不时地感到压力，但你如何知道自己的压力何时变得过大了呢？是当你无法正常睡眠时，当你的周末都在从过去一周的疲惫中恢复时，还是当你虽然仍在工作但感觉一切都比应有的更艰难时？也许最重要的问题之一是，你所承受的压力中有多少真正属于你自己。今天，我想帮你找出压力的来源，你可以改变什么，以及何时应该开始更认真地对待它。我是临床心理学家玛丽安·特伦特博士，这是《心理学其实》。在我们开始之前，如果你正在观看或收听这个节目，
I hope it's because you're a fan of the show, a returning fan of the show. I would be so grateful if you've got a moment to just check whether you're already following or subscribing to the channel or the show wherever you're accessing this episode. It is totally free. It helps me to help grow this show, which I hope is something you already love, or something that you will learn to love very soon. Thanks for being here. Now let's take a look at stress. Hi, welcome along to psychology actually. I am Dr. Marianne Trent. It's lovely to have you here. So stress, it is a big one and it affects all of us from time to time, some of us for longer than others. I think one of the first and most important ideas is to think about where this stress,
我希望这是因为你是这个节目的粉丝，或者是回归的粉丝。如果你有时间，我将非常感激你能检查一下是否已经关注或订阅了频道或节目，无论你在哪里收听这一集。这是完全免费的。它能帮助我发展这个节目，我希望这已经是你喜欢的内容，或者你很快就会喜欢上它。感谢你的到来。现在让我们来看看压力。嗨，欢迎来到《心理学其实》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。很高兴你能来。所以，压力，这是一个大问题，它时不时地影响着我们所有人，有些人受到的影响比其他人更长久。我认为第一个也是最重要的想法之一是思考这种压力，
where this pressure is coming from. And from my own experiences, both personally and clinically, it can be from a variety of different places. Often we can be our own worst enemy and it's that self-imposed pressure that might also feel very critical at times as well, that we're using to kind of spur ourselves on, but it's actually too. our detriment. There's a really, really interesting episode on this I did with Professor Paul Gilbert about compassion and the self-critic that I think you'll love. I will drop details in the show notes or in the description so you can catch up with that one at a later date. If you caught my recent blog series, which is the 2007 Diaries, which were emails that I had sent my friend
这种压力来自哪里。根据我个人和临床的经验，它可能来自各种不同的地方。通常我们可能是自己最大的敌人，那种自我施加的压力有时也会让人感觉非常苛刻，我们用它来鞭策自己，但实际上这反而有害。我与保罗·吉尔伯特教授关于同情心和自我批评进行了一次非常、非常有趣的对话，我想你会喜欢的。我会把详细信息放在节目说明或描述中，以便你以后可以补看那一集。如果你看了我最近的博客系列《2007年日记》，那是我发给朋友的电子邮件，
in 2007 when I was an early career. trying to get on to doctoral training. There was a lot of stress, there was a lot of pressure, and what I recognised was a lot of it was self-imposed. But as the emails unfold, I actually realised that a lot of it was kind of thinking about wanting to try and please my mum, make her happy. What I'm telling you as a 45-year-old is at some point in your life,
在2007年，当时我处于职业生涯早期，正试图进入博士培训。那时压力很大，有很多压力，我意识到其中很多是自我施加的。但随着邮件的展开，我实际上意识到其中很多是关于想要取悦我母亲，让她快乐。作为一个45岁的人，我想告诉你的是，在你生命中的某个时刻，
you've got to put that down, you've got to give up trying. You've got to really think about who it is your living, your life for and whether these kind of external metrics or what other people think of you or don't think of you is whether that matters really because we can't please people all of the time if we're setting ourselves up for that it's going to lead to hardship for you it's going to lead to potentially to burnout and to longer term impacts on your mental health and well-being. I'm aware that a lot of pressure can come from your peers as well especially if you're thinking that you've got like set ideas about times that you want to be doing things and you see
你必须放下它，你必须放弃尝试。你必须真正思考你到底是为了谁而活，以及这些外部指标，或者别人对你的看法是否重要，因为我们不可能一直取悦所有人。如果我们为此设定目标，那将导致你的困境，可能导致倦怠，并对你的心理健康和福祉产生长期影响。我也意识到，很多压力也可能来自你的同龄人，特别是如果你认为自己对想要做的事情有既定的时间表，而你看到
you see people around you doing those things or doing the things that you want to do. I'm not immune to that but I do try and hold in mind that old adage comparison is the thief of joy. We are different people than even people we've grown up with. We've had different experiences, we've had different factors that help us, different factors that harm us. I think even when you're looking at siblings, we are not the same people as our siblings. Even I look at my own children who are born two years and ten months apart to the same parents. And they have had very different experiences. One of my children, we moved house when he was 10 months old. And it was a very much kind of before and after phase of that. But also with me being
你看到周围的人在做那些事情，或者在做你想做的事情。我对此并非免疫，但我确实试着记住那句老话：比较是快乐的窃贼。我们与即使是一起长大的人也是不同的人。我们有不同的经历，有不同的因素帮助我们，也有不同的因素伤害我们。我认为即使你看待兄弟姐妹，我们也不是和兄弟姐妹一样的人。即使我看着我自己的孩子，他们相差两岁十个月，是同一个父母所生。但他们有非常不同的经历。我的一个孩子，在他10个月大时我们搬了家。那是一个非常明显的“之前”和“之后”的阶段。但由于我是
a second time parent, you know, the second time around, and with my dad being unwell with cancer when I was pregnant with my second child. My experience even of pregnancy and of giving birth and kind of recovering was very different both times around, especially because I already had an older child. So I think we can definitely think we should be the same as our siblings or we should be following the same trajectory. But sometimes we forget to think, do I even want what my sibling wants? Do I even find the same things appealing? And it's like, well, no. So is that a race that you're willing to run? The same with your peers. So if you're striving for the same profession, the same career, then of course it can make you feel like you are
第二次为人父母，你知道，第二次经历，而且在我怀第二个孩子时，我父亲因癌症病重。我两次怀孕、分娩和恢复的经历都非常不同，特别是由于我已经有一个大孩子了。所以我认为我们肯定会认为我们应该和兄弟姐妹一样，或者我们应该遵循同样的轨迹。但有时我们忘记思考：我真的想要我兄弟姐妹想要的东西吗？我真的觉得同样的事情有吸引力吗？答案是：不。那么，这是你愿意参加的比赛吗？你的同龄人也是如此。所以，如果你在追求同样的职业，同样的职业道路，那么当然这会让你觉得你
more comparable. But I really do when I reflect on my own career. I do think that I got, for example, onto clinical training at the point when I was ready for it. But I definitely added to the stress and the pressure by, you know, making myself apply for it sooner than realistically I was going to be able to do well. If by chance I'd been given a place to train as a clinical psychologist a year, certainly two years earlier, I would have floundered because I wasn't ready. So it's really worth thinking about your own career, your own experiences, when it comes to that. stress when it comes to that pressure am I genuinely wanting this right now? Do I genuinely feel like I'm ready or maybe am I chancing my arm and if I am I doing that? Why not be more mindful? Why not be more intentional about striving for these goals when the time is genuinely right
更具可比性。但在回顾我自己的职业生涯时，我确实认为，例如，我在准备好时才进入临床培训。但我肯定通过让自己比现实中能够做得更好时更早申请，增加了压力。如果我碰巧在一年前，甚至两年前就获得了临床心理学家的培训名额，我会因为还没准备好而挣扎。所以，当谈到压力时，思考你自己的职业生涯、你自己的经历是非常值得的。我真的现在想要这个吗？我真的觉得我准备好了吗？或者我是在冒险？如果我是在冒险，为什么不更谨慎一点？为什么不在时机真正成熟时，更有意图地去追求这些目标呢？
for me? You might feel pressure from colleagues, from managers, from from people in your team. You might feel pressure because you've got children or because you want to have children or you want to find a partner or someone to settle down with in order to have children. You might find pressure because you think I should be living by myself by now. I should be renting my own place. I should be buying my own place. The shoulds, the shoulds, the shoulds, the shoulds. That's a lot. Before we even begin to take into account your own health, the health of anyone around you, whether you've got dependents that need you. It is a lot. A lot indeed. So yeah, let's just have that little bit of audit to think about where that pressure is coming from, whether it's self-imposed,
对我来说？你可能会感到来自同事、经理、团队中人的压力。你可能会因为有孩子，或者因为想要孩子，或者想要找到伴侣或安定下来以便生孩子而感到压力。你可能会因为认为“我现在应该一个人住”、“我应该租自己的房子”、“我应该买自己的房子”而感到压力。这些“应该”，这些“应该”，这些“应该”，太多了。在我们开始考虑你自己的健康、周围人的健康、你是否有需要照顾的家属之前，这已经很多了。确实很多。所以，是的，让我们做一个小小的审计，思考一下压力来自哪里，无论是自我施加的，
whether it's coming from somewhere else, and just have that audit to start off with. Okay, so once we've done our little check-in and our audit, we're going to look at how much of this stress, how much of this pressure is controllable right now. What can you change? What can you influence? What do you maybe need to accept right now or find a worker, round for. I think this can be a really big factor. We can be really, really awful to ourselves when actually so many of the things that make life stressful for us, we might have very little control over. But again, some of those pressures, you know, really examining those shoulds. For example, if you're living independently at the moment and you're finding a bit of a financial
还是来自其他地方，首先进行这个审计。好的，一旦我们完成了小小的检查和审计，我们将看看这些压力中有多少是目前可以控制的。你可以改变什么？你可以影响什么？你现在可能需要接受什么，或者找到变通方法？我认为这可能是一个非常大的因素。当我们实际上对很多让生活变得有压力的事情几乎没有控制权时，我们可能会对自己非常、非常糟糕。但同样，检查那些“应该”是非常重要的。例如，如果你目前独立生活，并且感到一点经济
struggle, thinking about where that pressure is coming from, is there a should, you know, what stops you from getting a housemate or, you know, taking a step in a different direction and renting rather than owning or moving in with another friend, moving in with family members, just to allow yourself to get back on your feet, really. And, you know, you might treat that as a fixed period of time. You're not saying I'm going to go and do that forever. But I think we can really relieve the pressure on ourselves. When we just allow ourselves to do things, you know, for a few days, for a few weeks, for a few months, we set limits around that and then we can re-examine, you know,
压力，思考一下压力来自哪里，是否有一个“应该”？是什么阻止你找个室友，或者采取不同的方向，租房而不是拥有，或者和另一个朋友住在一起，搬去和家人住，只是为了让自己重新站稳脚跟。而且，你可能会把这视为一个固定的时间段。你不是说我要永远这样做。但我认为当我们只是允许自己做这些事情几天、几周、几个月时，我们可以真正减轻自己的压力，我们设定限制，然后我们可以重新审视，你知道，
perhaps when the dust is settled and just check whether we're still going to make the same decisions again. And I guess we'll juice some of that shame, take some of that shame away. So, for example, if you are making a change in a job or in a living situation or even a relationship, just be like, well, I couldn't have known what I know now before when I didn't have that context, I didn't have that experience, I didn't have that understanding, but now, now I'm here, I do. And I can now make a different decision based on having all of the information available to me. Okay, and the next section is where we're going to look at
也许当尘埃落定时，检查一下我们是否还会做出同样的决定。我想我们会减轻一些羞耻感，消除一些羞耻感。所以，例如，如果你正在改变工作、居住环境甚至人际关系，只需说：“好吧，在没有背景、没有经验、没有理解的情况下，我不可能知道我现在所知道的，但现在，我现在在这里，我知道了。我可以根据我所掌握的所有信息做出不同的决定。”好的，下一部分我们将看看
whether this stress you're experiencing is acute or chronic. And I'm going to share a little anecdote here to make you feel better about yourself. I was once in an interview for an assistant psychologist for an acute inpatient unit. You might be like, I don't know what that is. Now, if you're going to an interview, do make sure that you know what the terms mean in the job title itself, because I found myself in the very uncomfortable position of someone saying, you know, what is different about acute work to normal work? And I was found lacking. And, you know, well, acute.
你所经历的压力是急性的还是慢性的。我要分享一个小轶事，让你对自己感觉好一点。我曾经参加过一个急性住院病房助理心理学家的面试。你可能会想：“我不知道那是什么。”现在，如果你要去面试，一定要确保你知道职位名称中术语的含义，因为我发现自己处于一个非常尴尬的境地，有人问：“急性工作与正常工作有什么不同？”而我却答不上来。你知道，嗯，急性。
It's really bad, isn't it? No, that is not what acute means. Acute means kind of sudden onset without warning, you know, out of the blue. that's kind of what acute means, whereas the opposite of that would be a chronic condition. So, for example, you might have a chronic condition in your mental health, like bipolar disorder, schizophrenia, something like that that is going to be with you, you know, same as diabetes, you know, chronic health condition. But something acute might be, you know, a sudden upset stomach, a winter vomiting bug, or, you know, even a broken arm. You know, I broke my hand recently. That was an acute injury, something that came out of the blue that we'd expect to be able to work through it.
真的很糟糕，不是吗？不，那不是急性的意思。急性是指某种突发性的，没有预兆，你知道，出乎意料。这大概就是急性的意思，而它的反面是慢性疾病。例如，你可能在心理健康方面有慢性疾病，比如双相情感障碍、精神分裂症，类似这样的东西，它会伴随你，你知道，就像糖尿病，你知道，慢性健康状况。但急性可能是一些，你知道，突然的胃部不适，冬季呕吐病毒，或者，你知道，甚至是骨折。你知道，我最近手骨折了。那是一次急性损伤，出乎意料的事情，我们预计能够克服它。
But of course, when we're working with people for acute difficulties, they do have different needs than they would do with a chronic condition because we're needing to probably educate the person themselves a little bit about this in the way that we might not necessarily need to do with something chronic. the same is true with you and stress. If this is something that you're just kind of getting used to noticing and it's not really been around for you before, we may need to educate you a little bit about what stress is and how much of that is, you know, just going to happen and you've got to put up with it. So that's really what the focus of this video is to allow you to take a little bit of an audit and see what changes you could make. When it comes to thinking about whether it's a short-term people,
但当然，当我们与有急性困难的人一起工作时，他们确实有与慢性疾病不同的需求，因为我们可能需要对他们本人进行一点教育，这在处理慢性疾病时可能不一定需要。你和压力也是如此。如果这是你刚刚开始习惯注意到的事情，而且以前并没有出现过，我们可能需要对你进行一点教育，让你了解什么是压力，以及其中有多少是，你知道，只是会发生，你必须忍受它。所以这确实是本视频的重点，让你做一个小小的审计，看看你能做出什么改变。当谈到思考这是短期的
period of stress or a long-term period of stress, what we might notice is that our sleep might be impacted, our appetite, even our kind of sexual desires. If we're feeling really stressed, might be different than they usually are. You might notice it in your shoulders, that's where I notice it. And I notice it in my breathing as well. I'll be like, come on Marianne, take a breath. Just taking a moment to really check in with my own window of tolerance. And sometimes I'll do that soothing rhythm breathing cycle.
压力时期还是长期的压力时期，我们可能会注意到我们的睡眠可能会受到影响，我们的食欲，甚至我们的性欲。如果我们感到压力很大，可能会与平时不同。你可能会在肩膀上注意到它，那是我注意到它的地方。我也在呼吸中注意到它。我会对自己说：“加油，玛丽安，深呼吸。”只是花点时间真正检查一下我自己的容忍窗口。有时我会做那种舒缓的节奏呼吸循环。
So in through the nose, hold it for a moment out through the mouth. Hold that for a moment. I might do that three times just to reset myself, to get myself firmly back comfortably, hopefully, within my window of tolerance. I notice when I've got that tension in my shoulders, I can have a tendency to wear my shoulders as earrings, but they make much better shoulders than they do earrings.
所以通过鼻子吸气，屏住呼吸片刻，然后通过嘴呼气。屏住呼吸片刻。我可能会做三次，只是为了重置自己，让自己坚定地回到舒适的、希望是在我的容忍窗口内。我注意到当我肩膀有那种紧张感时，我会有把肩膀当耳环戴的倾向，但它们做肩膀比做耳环好得多。
So just checking in with my body, noticing whether I'm holding any tension in my jaw, and then I guess looking at how my concentration is as well. If you feel like your thoughts are moving a million miles a minute, that can be really hard and can be an indication of stress. I want to just pay a quick check-in to your physical health, to your heart, to your blood pressure. If you feel like maybe things aren't quite so healthy for you right now and your stress levels are high, please do consider getting a blood pressure meter reading, which usually you can do by popping into a local pharmacy, and they'll do that for you for free.
所以只是检查我的身体，注意我是否在下巴里有任何紧张感，然后我想看看我的注意力如何。如果你觉得你的思绪每分钟都在飞速运转，那可能真的很困难，并且可能是压力的迹象。我想快速检查一下你的身体健康，你的心脏，你的血压。如果你觉得现在情况可能不太健康，而且你的压力水平很高，请考虑测量一下血压，通常你可以通过去当地药店来完成，他们会免费为你做。
And if there's any problem with your blood pressure, they'll be able to give you the next steps that you might well take, which could involve booking an appointment with your nurse practitioner at your GP surgery, if you're in the UK, or alternatively with your GP. but we do know that stress can impact on our physical health. So please make sure if you're concerned about any symptoms, that you do check those out. Okay, let's think about the costs of this
如果你的血压有任何问题，他们将能够为你提供你可能采取的后续步骤，这可能包括在英国预约你的全科医生诊所的执业护士，或者预约你的全科医生。但我们确实知道压力会影响我们的身体健康。所以如果你担心任何症状，请务必检查一下。好的，让我们思考一下这些成本
because I think we can very much delude ourselves that it's okay. Like we can keep doing this to ourselves. But when we really take a little bit of a laser focus in and look at what the costs of this stress to you are, I think it can really help put things in perspective. For me, sleep is a big one. I'm not usually willing to squeeze my sleep because it makes me more rubbish in all other areas of my life. I'm a much worse parent. I'm a much poorer quality, more irritable wife when I haven't slept.
因为我认为我们非常能够欺骗自己，认为这没关系。就像我们可以继续对自己这样做。但当我们真正聚焦并看看这些压力对你的成本时，我认为这真的有助于把事情放在正确的角度。对我来说，睡眠是一个大问题。我通常不愿意压缩我的睡眠，因为它让我生活的所有其他方面都变得更糟。当我没睡好时，我是一个更糟糕的父母。我是一个质量更差、更易怒的妻子。
So it's just in everybody's best interest if Marianne gets at least eight hours of sleep a night because I'm just, I can be foul without it. I do not cope well in heat. So, you know, I try and keep a fan around, especially when it's been very hot lately. If you want to get a sensible answer out with me, don't keep me hot and don't make me overtired because frankly those are not good conditions for me. So if you're constantly overtired, you know, that then becomes a chronic condition in itself. So, you know, I have to be quite bounded about myself. I put my phone to sleep at 9.40 every night, the screen goes dark, and that tries to act as a little bit of a reminder. Don't go on me. Don't go on here. You know, I'm dead to you. Similarly, I've got a reminder on my watch telling me to go to bed. You know,
所以如果玛丽安每晚至少有八小时的睡眠，对每个人来说都是最好的，因为我没睡好可能会很糟糕。我不能很好地应对高温。所以，你知道，我尽量随身带着风扇，特别是最近天气很热的时候。如果你想从我这里得到一个明智的答案，不要让我太热，也不要让我过度疲劳，因为坦率地说，这些对我来说不是好的条件。所以如果你一直过度疲劳，你知道，那本身就变成了一种慢性疾病。所以，你知道，我必须对自己有相当多的限制。我每天晚上9点40分把手机调到睡眠模式，屏幕变暗，这试图起到一点提醒作用。不要用我。不要用这个。你知道，我对你来说已经死了。同样，我的手表上也有提醒，告诉我该睡觉了。你知道，
at the same time, really, 940, 945. I mean, I'm fairly entrenched in my habits now. I couldn't believe it when I was on training for the first time, and my supervisor at the time told me that she went to bed about 9 o'clock. I was like, you what? I think you what? But absolutely, when I was in the thick of it with my children, being very young, and I was managing, working full-time, I used to go to bed at 8.45, and I just, I couldn't think of any way around it, but those were the factors that I could control, the things that I could change.
在同一时间，真的，9点40分，9点45分。我的意思是，我现在已经相当习惯了。当我在第一次接受培训时，我简直不敢相信，当时的导师告诉我她大约9点就睡觉了。我说：“你什么？”我想“你什么？”但绝对地，当我的孩子们还很小，我忙于全职工作时，我曾经在8点45分睡觉，我只是，我想不出任何其他办法，但那些是我可以控制的因素，我可以改变的事情。
What I couldn't change was the fact that my child, my youngest child, is a really early riser. And, you know, before he started sleeping through, he would wake many, many times, like seven times a night. So just if I could try and get like an early chunk of sleep, so I could be asleep before midnight, you know, for a good few hours before midnight, hopefully if he wasn't waking up at that point, it would just feel like I'd put a little bit more energy tokens to. into that bank. And if you're all having this acute, stressful experience, it's whether you can kind of lean into just making some short-term changes to your sleep, which might make a big, big difference for you. It might even be that you need to make longer-term changes if you're always in sleep deficit, whether you can just be like, actually I, I care about current me, but I also care about future me. You know, I don't think I am just here for a good time.
我无法改变的事实是，我的孩子，我最小的孩子，是一个起得很早的人。而且，你知道，在他开始一觉睡到天亮之前，他会醒很多次，比如一晚七次。所以如果我能试着争取一段早期的睡眠，这样我可以在午夜前睡着，你知道，在午夜前睡几个小时，希望如果他那时没醒，那会感觉就像我往银行里多存了一点能量代币。如果你正在经历这种急性的、有压力的体验，关键在于你是否可以倾向于只做一些短期的睡眠改变，这可能会为你带来很大、很大的不同。如果你总是睡眠不足，甚至可能需要做出长期的改变，看看你是否可以只是说：“实际上，我关心现在的我，但我也关心未来的我。”你知道，我不认为我只是为了玩得开心而存在。
I would hope to think that I'm here for a long time, and therefore I need to invest in my own physical health, wellness, really. That's what I'm saying. So, you know, why is it okay for you to exist on five and a half hours sleep or less sometimes? Because you want to be up scrolling or you feel like you need some time to yourself at the end of the day. For me, I needed to invest that time in sleep. And it did mean that every day could feel a little bit monotonous, especially when the children were young. It didn't feel like I'd necessarily achieved like a thing or had that kind of relaxing sense of, but for those short period of time, although I know when you've got children,
我希望认为我在这里是为了长久，因此我需要投资于我自己的身体健康，福祉，真的。这就是我所说的。所以，你知道，为什么你有时靠五个半小时或更少的睡眠生存是可以的？因为你想熬夜刷手机，或者你觉得在一天结束时需要一点自己的时间。对我来说，我需要把那段时间投资在睡眠上。这确实意味着每一天都可能感觉有点单调，特别是当孩子们还小的时候。并不觉得我一定取得了什么成就，或者有那种放松的感觉，但对于那些短时间，虽然我知道当你有了孩子，
they can feel like long periods of time, I needed to spend my downtime where I wasn't immediately being needed by my kids sleeping. That's kind of how it boiled down for me. Because if we are knackered, then our physical health might well be impacted on as well. So our stress and our kind of short-term habits, whether we might be drinking, more units to cope with our stress the way we feel, that can impact on our physical health, our well-being. That steals from our sleep as well, of course, because we don't begin to start to get the benefit from sleep until we've processed any units of alcohol. And, you know, all of this stress, you know, when we're thinking about the costs, it's a joy stealer.
它们可能感觉像是很长的时间，我需要把我的休息时间花在睡觉上，而不是立刻被我的孩子们需要。这就是我总结出来的方式。因为如果我们精疲力竭，那么我们的身体健康也可能会受到影响。所以我们的压力和我们的短期习惯，无论我们是否可能在喝酒，用更多的酒精来应对我们的压力和我们的感受，那会影响我们的身体健康，我们的福祉。当然，这也偷走了我们的睡眠，因为在我们处理掉任何酒精单位之前，我们不会开始从睡眠中获得好处。而且，你知道，所有这些压力，你知道，当我们思考成本时，它是快乐的窃贼。
It's not going to make life feel very enjoyable unless, of course, you're looking at dopamine rewards. If you've got acute periods of stress followed by, you know, either a short-acting dopamine hit of reward for something that you get, that might feel like that's okay in a short term. But in longer term, we're really doing to think that life is supposed to feel enjoyable. It's not supposed to be all about stress, constant, constant, constant, because that will wear you down. That will impact on your relationships, both of your friends, with your family, maybe your intimate relationships, your partners, your children. Irritability is not fun. And what we don't
除非你正在寻找多巴胺奖励，否则它不会让生活感觉非常愉快。如果你有急性的压力时期，随后是，你知道，要么是短效的多巴胺奖励，因为你得到的东西，那在短期内可能感觉还可以。但从长远来看，我们真的要认为生活应该是愉快的。它不应该是关于压力，持续的、持续的、持续的，因为那会磨损你。那会影响你的人际关系，无论是朋友、家人，也许是亲密关系、伴侣、孩子。易怒是不好玩的。而且我们不
want is for you to constantly feel like you're ebbing and flowing. You're getting yourself back to feeling like you're able to go again while the time you're walking out the front door in the morning. But then by the time you come home again, you're so stressed, you're so overwhelmed, you're so depleted that you've then got to spend the whole time putting yourself back together again. I would really just encourage a little bit of reflection about whether it needs to be that way and whether there are any factors you can do so that things feel more comfortably within your stride. Things are also worth having a look at when this longer term stress might be contributing to a presentation of what we call burnout. I don't have time to cover that here, but I did a really lovely series called Burnout Bites with Dr. Claudeau.
希望你一直觉得自己在起伏不定。你让自己恢复到感觉能够再次出发的状态，直到你早上走出前门。但当你再次回家时，你压力太大了，太不知所措了，太枯竭了，以至于你必须花所有的时间把自己重新拼凑起来。我真的只是鼓励一点反思，思考一下是否需要那样，以及是否有任何因素你可以做，让事情感觉更舒适地在你的步调之内。当这种长期压力可能导致我们所谓的倦怠时，也值得一看。我没有时间在这里涵盖它，但我做了一个非常可爱的系列，叫《倦怠咬一口》，与克劳多博士一起。
Plumley, which is all about what burnout is and how it differs to a number of different things, including stress. There'll be details in the show notes and in the description. And the elephant in the room might be that if you are working right now, this stress might mean that actually you need to take a period of time off work so that you can address some life factors so that you can sort things out so that you can be kinder to yourself and get that breathing space to feel really well so that whatever your job is, that you feel like it's something that you are looking forward to, that you are enjoying. And the same thing with, you know, if the stress is coming from parenting or children or, you know, your friends, your family, how can you ask for help to
普拉姆利，这是关于什么是倦怠以及它与许多不同事物（包括压力）有何不同。节目说明和描述中会有详细信息。房间里的大象可能是，如果你现在正在工作，这种压力可能意味着实际上你需要休一段时间假，这样你就可以解决一些生活因素，这样你就可以整理好事情，这样你就可以对自己更友善，并获得那种呼吸空间，感觉真正良好，这样无论你的工作是什么，你都觉得它是你所期待的，你所享受的。同样的事情，你知道，如果压力来自育儿或孩子，或者，你知道，你的朋友、家人，你如何寻求帮助来
allow yourself some time to make some changes to help things feel more comfortable, more achievable and less like they're depleting you, more like they are enriching you. Just before we finish, I want to have a little bit of a kind of quick fire consideration. Number one, stress can come from our own personal values as well and how we feel that we're measuring up against them. So doing a little bit of a values-based exercise can be really helpful. If you'd like a full list of values, you can Google Act full list values. That will bring that up for you.
让自己有一些时间做出一些改变，帮助事情感觉更舒适、更可实现，并且不像是在消耗你，更像是它们在丰富你。在结束之前，我想做一个快速的考虑。第一，压力也可能来自我们自己的个人价值观，以及我们觉得我们如何衡量它们。所以做一个基于价值观的小练习真的很有帮助。如果你想要一份完整的价值观列表，你可以谷歌搜索“Act完整价值观列表”。那会为你调出来。
And you can have a little check-off about what you think your personal values are for your life, for your relationships, for your work, for many different life domains. Because sometimes that stress can be that conflict, that clash with our values, because it doesn't feel like we're living to our authentic self. Next is that high functioning stress is still stress. Even though you're getting all of your stuff done, it doesn't mean that that's okay. It means that you're very efficient, but it doesn't mean that that should be your norm. Thinking about our weekends and whether they are just a recovery debt.
你可以检查一下你认为你生活、人际关系、工作、许多不同生活领域的个人价值观是什么。因为有时那种压力可能是那种冲突，与我们价值观的冲突，因为它感觉不像我们在按照真实的自我生活。接下来是高功能压力仍然是压力。即使你完成了所有的事情，也不意味着那没关系。这意味着你非常高效，但这并不意味着那应该是你的常态。思考我们的周末，以及它们是否只是恢复债务。
So very much like they might be in the midweek where you feel like you're just like, oh. And then at the weekend, you just need to recharge and rest yourself so that you can physically carry on with your Monday morning tasks. It shouldn't really be that way. I do think the weekend should be a way of having a very different structure than your work week structure, but things that you enjoy, things that build you up, things that you look forward to, as well as, of course, some rest and recharge, but it shouldn't just be this constant ebb and flow. Having a little look at the borrowed expectations.
所以很像它们在周中可能的样子，你觉得你只是，哦。然后在周末，你只是需要充电和休息自己，以便你可以身体上继续你的周一早晨任务。真的不应该是那样。我确实认为周末应该是一种与你的工作周结构非常不同的结构，但做你喜欢的事情，建立你的事情，你期待的事情，当然还有一些休息和充电，但它不应该只是这种持续的起伏。看看借来的期望。
Is this actually my goal? Is it someone else's goal? Is this my timeline or someone else's timeline? Really do examine that. Stress, of course, lastly, before we finish, can narrow our perspective. Sometimes something comes into your inbox and you're like, I must do this immediately, but just taking a moment. to think, actually, I've got more pressing concerns that I need to address and whether I can
这是我真正的目标吗？是别人的目标吗？这是我的时间表还是别人的时间表？真的要检查一下。压力，当然，最后，在我们结束之前，可以缩小我们的视角。有时某事进入你的收件箱，你觉得“我必须立即做这个”，但只是花点时间思考，实际上，我有更紧迫的问题需要解决，以及我是否可以
add that to my to do list and I can come back to that because I know it is important. But right now, you know, I need to have this laser focus, but it can also stress can mean that we're just, we're very blinkered. We're not seeing other perspectives. So speaking to someone that you trust, someone that you care about, someone who's on your side. And that might include a therapist, a psychologist, can really help you to kind of consider other ways through when it's feeling really challenging. And one thing I'm going to leave you with is if you could reduce your life stress in this particular domain that you're struggling with at the moment by 10%, what would that look like? What could you do? What changes could you make? I'd love to know
把它加到我的待办事项清单上，我可以回到那个，因为我知道它很重要。但现在，你知道，我需要有这种激光般的专注，但它也可能意味着压力意味着我们只是，我们非常狭隘。我们没有看到其他视角。所以与你信任的人、你关心的人、站在你这边的人交谈。这可能包括治疗师、心理学家，真的可以帮助你考虑其他方式，当它感觉真的很具挑战性时。我要留给你的一件事是，如果你能把你目前正在挣扎的这个特定领域的压力减少10%，那会是什么样子？你能做什么？你能做出什么改变？我很想知道
in the comments whether you're watching on YouTube or on Spotify, you can make comments. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在评论中，无论你是在YouTube还是Spotify上观看，你都可以发表评论。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。